et en fait par rapport au fait de moi je
pense que c'est dur se projetaient de
dire ouais moi j'aurais réagi comme ça
je pense qu'on peut se tromper aussi sur
la manière dont on pourrait réagir
il ya tout un contexte ça veut dire
qu'avant le piège longtemps avant
georgia a dit à ses parents j'ai
rencontré comme ça c'est l'homme de ma
vie je veux faire ma vie avec
il est spécial il est un peu hautain et
l'arrogance vous allez voir parce qu'il
fallait pas que ce soit trop spécial le
jour du piège pour ce soit crédible
parce que sinon alors on alors parler
forcément un mec comme ça tu es obligé
de dire qu'il est spécial donc alors
adil un peu spécial mais s'il vous plaît
soyez un peu indulgents le jour où vous
le rencontrerez donc à tout ça qui fait
qu'ils arrivent au moment où il pense
que c'est un moment charnière de la vie
georgia et se disent on va pas la mettre
en porte-à-faux nous on aime notre fille
on va pas commencer à bastonner sont
suspendus ou phuc son nouveau mec
et du coup c'est le chirurgien ce risque
formidable ou aussi mais c'est vraiment
elle jouer la comédie
c'était très bien mais j'ai en fait je
n'avais jamais présenté un copain à ma
famille donc c'était bien compliqués
sont classés comme ça mais morini-bosc
isabelle morini bosc a plaisanté
mais voilà dès que j'avais des copains
se représentait pas sauf que là j'ai
déjà laissé l'optimalisation jean-mi
terme dans les choses a expliqué que
c'était un mec dans malgré elle avait
quelques victimes quelques problèmes
alors on va voir un extrait dès le début
de la caméra cachée louis gignac 2 le
tout vous présente son appât de ouf dans
le 16e arrondissement
j'ai cru un moment que c'était chez
guillaume genton bienvenue dans mon
appartement dans l'un de mes
appartements alors il ne s'agit pas d'un
appartement préféré je préfère largement
ou en hôtel particulier à saint claud je
vous parlais de du salon alors c'est un
salon finalement assez commun pas pas
grand chose de particulier j'ai cru
comprendre également que nous étions pas
forcément du même mois puis je m'appelle
donc louis gignac
je suis fils de françois vignac françois
est à la tête de tous mais plusieurs
sociétés pour la petite histoire il a
acquis cet appartement d'avoir un petit
pied-à-terre dans le 16
arrondissement bon ok elle m'a dit je te
le laisse signe qu'il sent pas à ton âge
tu le laisses à qui mieux mieux
bon moi j'ai la chance si vous voulez de
ne pas travailler
bon après j'ai envie de savoir déjà à ce
moment là qu est ce que vous vous dites
emilie parce que images la voix est si
c'est ça cauchemar oui mais dès le
départ j'ai eu un blocage parce que ça
correspondait pas du tout à ce que je
m'attendais que ma fille me ramène un
gentil fiancé il y avait déjà des choses
qui n'allaient pas mais je me suis dit
bon à vous d'essayer vous d'essayer de
je vais connaître je vais attendre je
vais patienter doit avoir certainement
mille et une caméra sur les ongles je le
vois voilà il ya eu beaucoup de patience
grâce à votre amour pour lancer ses
choix elle voulait nous le présenter
séquelles aline et donc à partir de là
on n'a pas le choix on attend il
enchaîne ensuite plein de clichés sur
les juifs
vous êtes donc je vais utiliser et c'est
vrai que c'est il a acquis d'enchaîner
les relais dans ce magnifique c'est un
vous avez parlé de quoi patrick bruel
des boulettes élagueurs les blés d'or
est insupportable j'ai eu un aperçu dans
la vérité si je mens je suis quelqu'un
de très ouvert d'esprit je n'hésiterai
pas s'il le faut même à mettre votre
petit chapeau là sur la tête là là le
petit le petit pan cake à tout mignon là
que vous avez à tous les jeux j'en ai
une pour vous autant que jeter un des
juifs à table qu'est ce qu'un juif dans
une forêt il c'est un rabbin déboires
alors bon petit prénom vous me disiez
que c'était gérard et il vit donc
j'imagine que ce sont des noms d'emprunt
gérard c'est gérard aujourd'hui je vous
présente charles et notre excellent
cuisinier ont sauté j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous cela devrait vous
ravir
charlie et de chez vous il est juif ni
des juifs comme vous vous devez sûrement
avoir beaucoup de choses à vous raconter
pouvait peut-être parler de patrick
bruel et boulettes tel aviv ces choses
là je n'avais jamais rencontré de juifs
le seul que je connaissais était le
pitre de la télévision cyril hanouna
oui or cela ne me donnait guère envie
d'en savoir davantage sur vous mais
finalement mon cuisinier osé couper et
très bien vous êtes juif et arabe en
même temps nos publics et c'est le
disons que vous cherchez les problèmes
mais vous avez toutes les tares même
parfois vous avez cherché des problèmes
n'ont jamais rien contre eux n'ont
évidemment collants il y avait de quoi
sera compris je connaissais une petite
brise là on peut rigoler sur 10 vous
pouvez y a des choses leur effet alors
bon il n'y a pas un moment où vous aviez
envie de lui envoyer une assiette dans
le jeu sincèrement oui mais toujours
avec rothen c'est ça non parce que vous
ne vous souvenez pas du tout c'est
l'amoureux de ma fille
c'est fou non meyer bon bout d'un virage
un amour aussi un tir moi j'ai fermé ma
bouche allumé commencer quelque chose ça
va exploser
je vais le regretter c'est incroyable
c'est surtout un papa rapport à tout ce
que moi j'ai pu sortir quelle théorie le
but aussi était de faire ressortir les
bons côtés de gérard emilie qui sont des
personnes qui sont très ouverte d'esprit
c'est un modèle de tolérance vraiment
vraiment les réseaux sociaux je vous le
dis il vraiment tout le monde a relevé
la tolérance la gentillesse des parents
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux emilie est
devenu une star parce que quand elle a
dit sur la torah
c'est même devenu amer dont les réseaux
sociaux puisque déjà sur la torah je
vais débuter ce mec elle m'a tuer on
fera ce qu'il va devenir culte sur la
torah je vais me le but sur la torah je
vais le but est survenu partout et oui
c'est dingue parce que sur la torah je
vais le but était près ce qu'on entend
de tout tir soir ça va rester il ya un
autre extrait je voudrais avoir c'est
quand après avoir enchaîné les clichés
sur les juifs la banlieue la tunisie
d'argent après avoir parlé de ses ex
ailleurs on va voir le moment où il
parle de sexe mais où il gêne à le monde
ah oui mais moi j'ai rien trouvé non
mais vous trouvez des métaphores le
nugget ca compris les majors c'est un
son horrible mais oui je le déteste vrai
mais moi aussi je le dff moi quand je me
vois j'ai envie de me tuer je me suis
rendu compte que georgia
on m'avait dans le ciboulot et qu'elle
n'était pas juste un bout de viande
évidemment il n'ya pas que ça il a
également sa splendide cros qui réveille
les morts
il faut dire que les échanges sms n'être
guère à construire une relation digne de
ce nom qui est compliqué et que j'en
avais plutôt mac là que me tirer sur
l'a10 touquet ce fut donc une délivrance
de retrouver georgia est de pouvoir à
nouveau la cire et sensuellement contre
moi et l'italien j'étais loin d'elle
j'avais des photos d'elle et ça me
permettait au moins 2 de faire passer le
temps oui vous allez où
oui bon on est content mais ils ont
compris mes coups je te voyais pas je ne
pouvais pas te palper il ya un moment où
se tirer sur leurs engins ça suffit wall
e je tiens à être clair dès à présent
avec vous là dessus il est hors de
question que vos raccourcis ciel prévue
de notre progéniture jeux permettent une
certaine familiarité
nous avons la chance d'avoir dans la
famille un grand ce gag de père en fils
je tiens absolument à ce que notre
lignée de ce gain reste intacte il faut
savoir qu'à ce jour
georgia et moi n'avons point encore
copuler tout ça pour vous dire
qu'effectivement à je n'ai pas encore
mis
mon petit nuggets dans le pot de
mayonnaise mais ayant la trentaine
maintenant bien tassés il est vrai que
cela commence à me tirer sévèrement sur
la piste où kate vitesse accélérée alors
est-ce que ça avance mais est-ce que tu
apprends des princes parker ou c'est que
de 50%
c'est un texte que j'apprends je le
répète même chez moi je tourne en rond
je répète c'est comme une pièce de dell
et lenovo habitants quittent le négoce
la phase a été préparée mais tout ce
qu'il ya derrière quand je parle des
photos et tous ces partis en impro parce
que je vois qu'à ce moment là ils sont
tellement c'est le malaise faut
l'entretenir il n'a pas bien sûr et puis
en fait vous me laissiez tellement de
place parce que je crois qu'il me lire
avec une curiosité c'était de savoir ce
que j'allais sortir à la fin parce que
moi c'était un raisonnement c'était pour
aller d'un point a vers un point b
et à chaque fois elle disait à tout
autant laisse le dérouler parce que j'ai
toujours eu beaucoup quand même je
parlais beaucoup parce que je voulais
avancer voir un petit césar mais vous
voulez vous attendez mis en moi ouais je
vous saviez que ça n'est pas la fin
avait pas fini nous a pas laissé trop
parlé c'est vrai c'est vrai que l'équipe
ils arrêtent pas là laurent gerra était
impatient et un autre personnage qui a
fait nous aurions parlé c'est victor le
majordome c'est là qu'il a fait craquer
d'ailleurs voilà pour mon regard des
habitants vous n'aimez pas débarrassé
voilà aubin installe toi ici où on
m'attend dans le sens d'une lourde
intervention au pied c'est le début de
la retrouve chez ses deux jambes avec
force essaie de joindre réaliser la
chance vous avez pensé à ceux qui n'ont
pas de travail
allez disposer autour sous os ou fera
face en blanc je suis bien vernet
voilà avec un fort elle envoûte rose
l'autre jour je me rends dans la chambre
des personnels mais qu'est ce que je
trouve sous la litière de victor trois
bouteilles de gens la moisson du diable
et de la débauche vous dépêcher victoire
ne va pas y passer la journée au lit le
ciel oui monsieur
pour moi ce sera un excellent revers de
konya par contre juste un verre car
ferry un cognac cette maniaque de cognac
on évitera pourrait manquer de respect
[Musique]
possible que vous fais toi calme tout
mais comment tu peux accepter ça comment
c'est possible
[Rires]
un truc cyril qui est gay qui est jouée
le majordome
ils excellent fait et l'excellence et
surtout pour faire le mec avait vraiment
mal aux pieds qui pouvait pas s'asseoir
et nabih berry une un caillou dans sa
chaussure
pendant les quatre heures de repas parce
que ça durait quatre heures leur pain
oui il reste avec sa dent il est resté
debout je l'empêché de s'asseoir en fait
parce que oui vous les mains santé qui
souffrait il y avait le disait ce qui
grimaçait tout le temps mais pour
s'imprégner encore plus son rôle et la
vérité ou dans la chaussure pour faire
vraiment un pour s'offrir vraiment c'est
le vote meilleur moment c'est quand il
vous a dit que c'est une caméra cachée
j'ai pas réagi tout cela paraît je
n'étais la caméra cachée c'est vrai que
j'ai bu j'ai vu se regarde et on va le
voir vous allez voir au début c'est en
allant ya un autre truc aussi c'est
qu'au départ vous fumez de la sécurité
18 coup calavi donnez moi des cigares et
cigarettes gens regardent ça aurait peut
être votre style de jean louis pas du
tout après greg wood ou pas oui j'en ai
il a vu non à oui biensur et la ville
veut dire si on vous dit ben il a rigolé
il est avec sa famille
et voilà c'était une petite présentation
bien la télé comédienne qu'on fait quoi
dans la vie je suis dans l'immobilier
accord mais bon après ça vous a donné
envie peut-être un voile accès bas ça
agréable c'est sympa c'est alors et
c'est un beau métier
on va voir quand avoir senti vous
annonce que c'est une caméra cachée
c'est vrai que on le voit vous ne
réagissez pas vous êtes encore non
tellement énervé est tellement sous le
choc que vous réagissiez garde côtes et
moi s'il vous plaît on peut pas faire
marche arrière
on peut pas faire marche arrière si j'ai
vu le tambour rouge que vous rencontriez
lui en aller en sarthe
effectivement je l'ait déjà féconde et
je ne supportais plus d'en avoir lourd
sur la vie stockett
donc j'ai féconder votre fille est
d'ailleurs j'ai l'échographie à vous
montrer regarder magnifique sarthoise
une [ __ ] y regarder ce petit bébé il est
terriblement trognon regarder à
l'intérieur mais né à l'échographie
aurait l échographie en fait vous voilà
c'est une belle nouvelle regarder les
réjouissances regardez tamansourt qui
sont là pour vous est fait piéger
c'était une caméra cachée
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas en danger à tout ça est
faux qui est complète on les voit et il
ya plein de gens qui sont dit vous êtes
vous êtes vous n'avez plus géniaux parce
que vous n'êtes pas trop énerver
on a quand même des scènes où emilie est
l on peut plus que vous avez tous
regarder un film et jari stehn cas mais
je vous le dis c'est une pièce de
théâtre avec les acteurs qui savent pas
qu'ils sont dans une c2 piégés à
l'intérieur c'est ça et aussi ses
intérêts en aura on va mettre d'ailleurs
un making of d'une heure trente sur
notre chaîne qui retracera tous les
couples ce qu'on a raté ce piège en 2018
on l'a mis à la pause et rés avant
d'avoir en 2000 26 ans en 2020 qu'on a
tourné
c'est ça c'était ouais c'est ça les
larmes de georgia sont sincères à la fin
c'est ça en fait l annonce quand même à
ses parents et toi tu t'es peut-être
visualiser en train de leur dire que tu
étais enceinte incroyable parce que
j'aimerais courir jouer
je veux tellement bien mais à mon avis
aussi vous aviez de la peine pour vous
parce qu'elle m'a dit moi je n'ai
honnêtement je suis même tombé en train
de pleurer même si une caméra cachée
tout ça au bout d'un an j'en fais plus
j'avais envie de tout lâcher gérance à
un peu le ça y est c'est fini et c'est
la pression qui retombe en enfance
on n'avait que quatre heures de repas
c'était pour vous ces salons 80 elles
ont pour vous abbas et sur actions
c'était très bon nicolas et vous n'avez
pas eu peur de les perdre un moment
donné parce qu'il est allé tellement
loin dans le truck ans et henry je me
suis dit on se le vivons déjà on s'est
tellement renseigner sur tes parents
avant le piège et ont lors on n'arrêtait
pas dire mettez sur talus le test qu'on
a fait est sûr qu'ils vont pas partir
parce que même nom se disait mais ils
vont partir c'est pas possible
et tu as tu nous garantissait tu disais
mes parents il même tellement que pour
moi ils resteront et me laisseront
jamais tout seul avec toi j avais assez
clair on aurait pu s'affirmer en
l'emmenant donc un laser de là sinon
serais pas partie en la laissant avec ce
retrait dans la voiture le long des bras
leurs voix plus
il est incroyable c'est fini vous êtes
quand même énervé un petit moment émilie
après avoir enchaîné les clichés sur les
juifs la banlieue la tunisie l'argent
après d'abord par les textes et commence
un peu en avoir gros sur la patate
disons qu habituellement je ne me
retourne jamais sur des filles de basse
classe mais j'ai tout j'ai finalement
été séduit par son manque d'éducation et
sa spontanéité qui lui confère vironneau
un petit côté rebelle qui me plus sombre
des questions c'est quoi un manque
d'éducation
on peut équiper des mondes d'ananas non
mais ça peut pas faire ça veut dire quoi
dix minutes je disais ça dans le sens
opposé d'un nano et je m'en fous ce
n'est pas à nous de faire des efforts
mais bon pourquoi mais c'est à vous mais
partir et je ne sais pas ce que vous me
rencontrer mais l'agglo et les nouveaux
gros c'est même pas contenir que c'est
de me rencontrer de rencontrer mon mari
keith et visa vous êtes les premiers
responsables de ces criantes lacunes
c'était aujourd'hui je dois recoller les
pots cassés par votre faute sur votre
papa d'une part on assiste montréal y
profiter y arrête de me dire je vais lui
parler
ça y est ça va sur le genre enfin vous
disais quelque chose d'intéressant
gérard en loge tout à l'heure c'est que
il y avait des moments où on faisait de
la connivence un type l'on est à nouveau
en connivence à le montage 1h30 de
pièges mais ces quatre heures le vrai
repas donc ça veut dire qu'on redescende
et puis on repartait plus fort et à
chaque fois vous m'accordez une deuxième
chance un peu sur la torah juppé
oui j'aurais dit non mais là où greg est
phénoménal c'est qu'en fait il à
contre-courant aujourd'hui on passe son
temps être dire ici souvent on peut plus
rire de tout et rien dire est que ça lui
va très très loin il hausse tout en fait
il ya des clichés sur la banlieue
regarder mais c'est bien pourquoi y'a
rien de raciste parce qu'il ya une telle
humanité qu'ils dégagent de ça que je
trouve justement sator loupé et on
arrive à tout dire qu'on s'est bien fait
vous vous voyez un travail sont
exceptionnels bien sûr c est regardé ce
qui lie sur les banlieues se remonte
vous vivez donc si j'ai bien compris du
côté des mines a dans le 93 dans la
famille que tu fasses tes valises
pourtant dallest parce que les lilas ça
sent tout sauf la rose c'est non non ça
ne sent ni la roque divine il a rapport
aux fleurs ça sent plutôt si vous aussi
nous devons rester dans le végétal ça
sent plutôt le haschich par rapport à la
drogue que prennent les jeunes vous
savez que les lilas ça reste quand même
la commune côté du 93 j'imagine qu'on
avait des proches qui sont déjà tombés
sous les balles des proches tombés sous
les balles lors de lors de rixes entre
bandes rivales
habituellement je n'échange que très peu
voire même jamais avec les banlieusards
voire pire les provinciaux nous ne
sommes pas du même monde
et c'est antoine n'a pas inquiet pareil
non oui mais j'ai une montre moi 70000
euros 1
comment gagner vous votre chronique
office alors en tout cas sachez ml oui
je vous trouve très courageuse
j'applaudis des deux mains
on le fait de se lever chaque matin pour
aller trifouiller les cheveux gras des
prolétaires ya c'est vrai que je vous le
dis et je redis ce ne sont pas du tout
des comédiens voilà il faudra vraiment
pas comment comment ou du comment tu les
avait contactés en fait
alors en fait on a un site qui s'appelle
zhu buzz qui nous a aidés à trouver les
parents de géorgiens
parce que du coup on a lancé une annonce
désespérée puisque comme je te disais on
a raté le piège d'une première fois on
n'arrivait pas à trouver région kctu
tata contacter d'abord j'ai un tu lui as
dit en fait explique nan je demande
c'est toi qui a vu l'annoncé de jeu buzz
par une amie et du coup on nous a
contactés en disant j'ai les parents
parfaits faut qu'on les pièges
on a reçu on a en fait un watt ça parce
que tu es à marseille à ce moment là
s'est connecté on a demandé un maximum
d'informations sur vous on a essayé
d'analyser voir si tu étais le bon
profil c'est justement il était
attachant parce que c'est c'est bien
d'avoir des gens qui soient nerveux mais
c'est surtout attachant qui serait qui
est important surtout sarclage aussi
long et du coup on a on a demandé à
maxime l'information s'inventer une
histoire notre passé savoir où on
s'était rencontrés ont naturellement ses
rangs voilà tout ça on lui a dit voilà
il faut que je tienne tel discours à tes
parents faut vite que tu leur dise j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un il veut vous voir
vite dans sur la cité quelques deux
semaines ou peut-être c'était un après
bon faut qu'on fasse ce repas donc tout
ça s'est déroulé comme ça on verra tout
dans le métier on vous montrera tout
dans le making-of façon est ce que
pouvait juste nous refaire pour les
téléspectateurs sur la torah juillet
parce que c'est vrai alors il faut que
je le regarde et le rire non lui rien
que je rêve je vois la sorte
[Musique]
merci mon soutien mais son formidable